[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author my daughter is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five and some say
the advice is worth exactly what you pay
for it this is a show about your life
your career
your money your work your relationships
you and we're here to help you with all
of it in this crazy mixed up angry world
out there there's still some people out
here with common sense and the good ones
end up being attracted to this show
we're glad you're here open phones again
triple eight eight two five five two two
five adam's gonna start us off in
atlanta georgia hi adam welcome to the
ramsey show
uh hi dave and rachel how are you both
doing today
great man what's up
so my question is whether i should buy
or rent um so a little background i'm
currently serving in the army uh getting
ready to move duty stations here this
summer
my next assignment will be for about
three years and i'm just wondering what
is going to set me up
in the best position to buy a rent
so great great question adam number one
thanks for
your service we appreciate that um
everyone that serves we we greatly honor
you and appreciate you
and when it comes to
um
buying a home and staying in something
long-term
kind of the role of thumb that we always
use is around five years so if you're
going to be somewhere five years
and permanently stay there then
investing into a home
is a great option um but we've talked to
a lot of military folks out there that
you know that you guys in essence of
what you do that you you are moving
constantly and sometimes it's it's more
of a headache to own something and try
to keep that going versus just renting
because oftentimes it's short term like
you said just three years
uh so usually the rule of thumb there is
is if you're there five years or longer
that's what i would recommend buying
here's the two sides of the equation
adam that you and you can run the
equation for yourself all right
what happens too many times is guys in
the military gals in the military think
oh owning a home is always smart
everybody should own a home you ought to
buy a house shout out by a house and
they buy a house in a military community
where there's constant turnover and it's
very difficult to sell a house because
there's always a bunch of houses for
sale
also they don't always go up in value as
much because there's always a bunch of
houses for sale and then they end up oh
well i'll just rent it and you look up
at the end of your career and you got
seven rental properties in seven
different cities that were former
residences that you became a landlord by
default well that we don't want you to
do and you don't want to do that okay
now the times that you can buy is what
rachel's saying when you reach a point
in your career or
you uh take the type of a position in
your career where you're going to be
there a little longer it's going to make
sense
even if you're there only three years
there's a few times it might work and
here's how you can actually do the math
to make the decision okay
you can contact one of our elps in the
area one of our real estate elps in the
area and you're looking for two things
in that market
and uh i would go back a couple of years
um i wouldn't i wouldn't count uh this
last 12 months because they're weird
in the real estate market but other than
the last 12 months i would say what is
the average appreciation rate within 5
or 10 miles of the area i'm looking at
okay and if the average appreciation
rate is three percent and you're there
three years you're going to lose money
when you resell you understand
okay but if the average appreciation
rate not counting whacked out 21 okay or
or the end of 20 if the average
appreciation rate is 7 to 10 well it's
going to go up 30
while you're there
and you know you could probably make
money agreed
right but you need to be able to resell
it and that's the second statistic
you're looking for which is dom
days on the market what's the average
days on the market on homes within a 10
mile radius of where i am looking if the
average days on the market is 270 that's
nine freaking months you're stuck in
this house
you can't give it away
you don't buy there you follow me
but if the average days on the market
within a 10 mile radius is three days
or 21 days or something like that that's
a pretty hot market oh by the way you're
going to see these numbers correlate
if you're seeing good uh good increases
in value you're going to see short days
on the market
you're going to see them together if you
see long days on the market you're going
to see lower increases in value and it
literally depends on the area
i mean if your navy and you get
stationed in san diego you probably roll
in and out of that baby and make some
money yeah but if you're in
the plains of kansas and there's no one
within a 20-mile radius except military
people
you're not going to get out of that one
you know that's not going to be a
long-term investment for you unless
you're there long-term so that's the way
you can run the numbers on it and tell
but most of the time i'd say 90 of the
time when you do all that you're gonna
discover if i'm here three years it
doesn't make sense well and even that i
mean
whether it's you know military or we
even talk to to young couples that you
know they just newlyweds they get
married they want a house but just the
factor of owning a home and everything
that it takes to keep up with that
there's just a level of that
responsibility you always have to filter
through when you own a home because it's
it's all yours the more crap
the more crap you own the more repairmen
you have to know 100 so
so there so sometimes it's you know and
i think within the military i know
different positions take you know
different levels of stress for sure but
especially if you're in a stressed
filled
you know role in the military there's a
part of you that's like there's a yeah
just don't worry yeah it's something you
want to worry about when you're renting
or especially
we'll call the landlord no i don't know
there's something i like about that yeah
call the landlord and go hey your house
is broke come fix it come fix it
there's something to be said for that
for sure
open phones at
825-5225 thank you for joining us kelly
is in traverse city michigan hi kelly
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and rachel it's a pleasure
talking to you both you too how can we
help
uh my husband and i are disagreeing on
what to do with his student loans
we currently owe seventeen thousand
dollars we have the cash right now to
pay them off
um but we're both registered nurses here
in northern michigan and the ceo of our
hospital
is implementing a retention plan which
is
forgiveness for twelve thousand dollars
of federal student loans
but because it's a retention plan it is
two hundred dollars a month for the next
you know four to five years
and
i would like to just pay them off and be
done with it not have the debt hanging
over our heads but my husband um
thinks that taking advantage of this
free money is the smarter
it's not supportive
your husband is wrong
so what do you do in your marriage when
your husband's wrong
wow
kelly i'm sorry i feel for you i do
and this is hard because here's
oh
let's come back to this this is a good
conversation okay all right
hold on hold on kelly we'll come back
rachel wants rachel wants to be
reasonable hold on we'll come right back
with you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
here on the ramsay show we're talking
with kelly in traverse city michigan uh
her
hospital is offering a 12 000
forgiveness over five years
um and uh they owe seventeen thousand
student loans they have the money to pay
it off she wants to pay it off her
husband doesn't what do i do was her
question and i was joking with her and
saying what do you do when your
husband's wrong but um so anyway that's
how far we got is that a fair summary of
what you told us kelly
yeah okay
okay so what i was going to say kelly is
and again this is a little stereotypical
so it's not true 100 of the time but
generally men
tend to lean more on
kind of that the the logic
math side a little less on the emotional
side right women can i feel like can
naturally go there a little bit quicker
than men so when it comes to debt and
and even student loans there's this this
idea that yeah if i can just do the math
it's going to play out right so he's
looking at the math he's seeing the
logic and he's thinking yeah i mean
someone's going to pay this off this is
great
where you're feeling on the other end we
have the money and there's a level of of
probably less stress a level of freedom
that you know you're going to experience
when this is paid off am i am i right or
wrong is this correct right yeah yes
so whenever couples do tend to disagree
especially when it comes to money um i
think
going to him because you hesitated when
he said what do you do when your
husband's wrong uh so i don't know how
you guys do conflict i don't know how
you come to decision making uh we've
only been talking for about 30 seconds
but
one thing i really would encourage you
to do is to go to him and and we always
say tell him your why
and and and that why
may not make logical sense because to
him he's thinking i'm going to get free
money and someone's going to pay this
off and you know
x y and z
and to really unpack with him
you what you're seeing what you're
feeling
and why you want this paid off and that
could be because you don't want your
destiny in someone else's hands we talk
about that a lot when it comes to
student loans a lot of people depend on
whether it's
dc or these programs that say hey if you
work for us 10 years we'll pay it off
who knows what's going to happen right
in all this time and when you're passive
and you let other people
handle your future you're letting go of
really the will to go and say i can
change my life so there could be an
ownership issue that you struggle with
for you maybe you are just stressed with
just having debt whether it was a car
loan or student loan doesn't matter
you don't like having the debt i don't
know what it is for you kelly but
whatever that why is of i
i want this paid off because we have the
money
go to him with that first and foremost
versus blaming or
being accusatory uh really when you go
with that why i think it's one of the
best ways to start and open up the
conversation
so that is really good counsel let me
give you the let me tell you why he's
wrong and maybe that'll help too
okay okay if you told me they were going
to pay you 12 000 as a retention bonus
in 12 months
i'd go with him on it
but you're not you're getting two
hundred dollars a month it's not speed
it's not spit that's twenty four hundred
dollars a year
right and this is dragging out forever
forever now and this is this is golden
handcuffs in a highly volatile
covered laced vaccination world
that you live in the middle of
where where healthcare workers are
on the front line
and you don't want to be handcuffed to
anything you want to keep your freedom
because you may have to make some
different choices
and this is golden handcuffs
yeah right now the the interest is zero
percent so interest isn't relevant that
side is it
right but when once it goes back that's
90 200 isn't even covering the interest
that's a good point too
mathematically but here's the thing it's
dragging out too long it's the free
money is not worth the trade-off
for the length of time if it was a short
period of time
i would i would i would throw the flag
and i would argue with you that he was
right
okay
but it's too long it's drug out the
borrower is slave to lender
and rachel's right there's a sense that
of release there's a sense of
employment freedom
of medical freedom
your medical freedoms aren't
trapped
you've got you get to choose what
happens in these if you don't handcuff
yourself to one particular situation and
the trade-off is not worth it here
because it's just too long
and uh you know that
and all of this to say
five years from today ten years from
today which of these two decisions puts
you guys in the best position
paying off today paying off today yeah
and the reason it puts you in the best
position is it frees you up to work
wherever you freaking choose to work
that is best for you
and you don't you're not looking over
your shoulder going oh but they got that
student loan forgiveness thing you know
and you're not you're not handcuffed to
it uh and so it's golden handcuffs is
what it is and that's why they're doing
it by the way
it's retention and it's why they're
dragging it out
it's to keep you in a volatile
environment for health care workers
uh you guys are you know that that world
is has been going through medical hell
now it's starting to go through legal
and vaccination hell and there's just a
huge turnover huge problem there's going
to be a huge shortage of health care
workers
with what's going on out there and it's
the same thing with teachers same thing
with policemen
and when the teachers the health care
workers and the policemen in our culture
are all being mistreated at the same
time
we as a culture
we've got some issues coming that aren't
gonna be pretty yeah and you're gonna be
caught right in the middle of that
you're gonna be caught right in the
middle of that trapped by this one
decision to get a little bit of free
money it ain't worth it kiddo it ain't
worth it and again this is what we
always say here on the show personal
finance it's 80 behavior it's 20 head
knowledge the head knowledge part the
logic part that he's functioning in
there's so much more when it comes to
money than just looking at just the math
and so but but when you sit in the math
that's what he's playing over and over
and over
his math formula is wrong my point okay
because here's the situation here's
what's coming in her world she's going
to have the opportunity to
raise her income by more than twelve
thousand dollars by changing jobs
62 times in the next five years yep and
she doesn't want to be trapped with a
stupid little 12 000 benefit over here
in that particular job 100 no i hear
that totally but again he has to be able
to get above that and look at all the
options on the table yeah yes partly
matt he went down he went down the
rabbit hole and got stuck down there
with a little short-term
a little limited vision on the math
that's my point yeah and he's super
nerding
and didn't he and missed some of the
variables yes open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us america daniel
is in la hey daniel welcome to the
ramsay show
hey how are you better than i deserve
how can i help
hey yeah so my wife and i currently live
in a 850 square foot house that we
bought two bedroom one bath i work from
home and we have a baby on the way
um
and we were wondering if we should take
money and buy or build like a accessory
dwelling unit or a granny flat in the
back of our house we have a little more
space so that when our parents come
visit
and when i work from home is a little
more space
might do it for work for home but not
for parents visiting parents visiting go
to a hotel
okay because the math doesn't make sense
i mean what you're going to spend there
so they can spend the night eight nights
a year five nights a year it doesn't
make sense but for you to have a place
to work with a kid screaming in an 850
square foot deal yeah i'm in
okay so it would cost about 180 thousand
dollars and we can pay cash what
it's la yeah no it's not la la's got the
same construction cost it's just the
dirt under it that's expensive
and he's already got the dirt what are
you building back there dude
uh
we can maybe build like a two bedroom
two bath
house
yeah you're building a house
i thought you were building a little
room back there
um
yeah i think the plan would be to build
like a two bedroom two bathroom yeah you
you may be over building the
neighborhood you need to look at that
that's that's a big project you might be
better off just to move to something
that's not 850 feet
this is not a renovation this is a tear
down rebuild
i mean
that's a big move right there i think
you could be overbuilding your
neighborhood you may want to take that
180 and go to a different place
and live that's got the square footage
all together and nice and built in and
don't over build your neighborhood be
careful i really think there's a chance
you are
come to think about
850 feet
yeah it's
one of those
mini-house things
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's book launch here
book launch week this week here at
ramsey baby steps millionaires is uh
selling
very well thank you very much we
appreciate all of you picking the book
up how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
we had an exciting event last night with
rachel cruz george camel and i uh
talking about building wealth in 2022 it
was a free live stream for about 150 000
folks joined us online and then we had
about 1500 in the audience it was a lot
of fun
yes it was it was a great great event
good stuff in the lobby of ramsay
solutions on the debt free stage
brittany is with us hi brittany how are
you hi dave hi rachel i'm great how are
you better than we deserve i like your
t-shirt i'm debt-free thank you i like
it i like it i like it where do you live
akron ohio cool welcome to nashville how
much data have you paid off 138
346 dollars dang girl
amazing get it get it how long did this
take 47 months wow four years
and how much uh what was your range of
income during that time i ranged from 57
000 up to 74 000 and then covet kind of
killed the side hustles so i ranged
about 68 000 last two years good good
for you what kind of debt was your 138
all student loans all student loans you
gave sallie mae her eviction notice yes
tossed the old woman in the street
i like it good for you well done
well done what was your degree in i have
a masters of occupational therapy okay
and that's what you're doing i assume
yes
good good for you
okay so tell us your story what happened
four years ago that started you on this
whole journey to get out of debt so i
just remember standing in my kitchen
scrolling through facebook and my friend
from high school emily she posted about
her debt and her debt-free scream
and i immediately messaged her and said
we have to talk
so
i she asked me questions and
what my bank account looked like what i
was doing for retirement and she just
walked me through the baby steps and she
said drain your account to a thousand
dollars and
stop contributing to retirement and the
next day that's what i did wow dang
coached your ride up yes yes wow and
then you you just followed what she said
or you got plugged into us or what so um
for christmas actually my boyfriend
bought me financial peace university
um and so i listened to you every day on
the um on the podcast
so some days i had really long drives
and i listened to you for hours if i had
a five minute drive i'm still listening
to you wow wow
well thank you so brittany that's a
pretty quick turnaround just from a
facebook post so up until that point
were you feeling the tension of the debt
was it like oh i'm gonna have this for
like was it just laura you feeling like
before that and then you kind of saw
this ray of hope of like oh my gosh i
can get rid of this yeah so i actually a
couple months before that signed for a
mortgage and my student loan was higher
than my mortgage
um and so that was just kind of a
tipping point that was in my head like
this this is going to take me forever to
pay off and then
the website of your student loans is
great and it shows you the chart of how
much you'll actually pay off with your
terms so it was 270 thousand dollars oh
wow
and so i saw that and you know in two
years uh my death
getting out of grad school my dad was
127 thousand dollars and then when i
started being intentional it jumped to
138 000.
wow dang so that's it was just kind of
i'm going to have these for the next 20
25 years
there's no way out of this and then your
friend's post gives you a glimmer of
hope yes and that's what you're doing
for somebody today i hope so somebody's
watching this debt-free scream right
this second and they're going wait a
minute
wait a minute it doesn't have to be this
way i can get out i can be free i can be
free
it's hard though isn't it it is it's a
long four years yes yes what was your
best side hustle um personal training ah
that makes sense
occupational therapy i bet you're a
great trainer
you actually would know what the flip
you're doing that's cool good good for
you what was that so what was the
hardest part for you um you know it was
really it was a lonely
journey because you have your friends
going out buying stuff and or inviting
you out
and then you would just watch the
numbers sometimes stay stagnant so
i remember i saw the
debt i was working on was eighty
thousand dollars and um um but how the
loans work they're little tokens so you
have like the little loans in between
but you see one going down while your
other ones are just kind of staying
there so i saw one loan just stick at
like sixty thousand dollars
for a long time and like this is never
going to go away
that is hard and it can i mean it would
feel isolating right i mean when you're
when you are you're you're doing it by
yourself as you're single right and
you're like i'm in that and there's a
blessing and a curse to that right that
you it's just you that you got to do it
but it's also just you that has to do it
and there's a level of intentionality
that i always think when people do this
on their own obviously you had great you
know you had friends around you i hope
and supported you who were your biggest
cheerleaders definitely my boyfriend
levi um he supported me a lot he
actually walked into the bathroom and
saw
my razor without the handle and he went
to the roadway i'm like no no that's
mine and he's like
it has no hand i'm like it's it's fine
like
so then
like the next month he like bought me
razors and he's like here
please this is pitiful this is really
pitiful you need a razor yes like please
like put this in your budget um so he he
definitely was and whenever i would get
too zoned in and you know like every
single quarter or penny he would reel me
back in and be like it's okay you're
going to make it through this yeah
that's good that's good good balanced
yes like it like it well done i'm proud
of you
how's it feel to be free amazing i'm
just working through baby step three now
and that's harder than baby step two i
know you guys say that a lot and you
know it's a few months
but it's hard because you don't have
that debt anymore yeah
and you're still saving to get to it but
it feels so great that i don't have that
lurking over my head absolutely i mean
138 thousand dollars is gone that's
pretty stinking incredible yes well done
very cool good job good job good job
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you have to be
intentional you have to follow the
budget um dave you talk about when your
wife has a feeling
i remember i had a feeling one january
that i was going to come into a big
expense and i was like okay i'm just
going to hoard all my money see what
happens and then march came and my car
broke down
and um you know you go to different car
places and they're just you just feel
slimy when you go to leave and
i found a car from a reliable guy and it
was the exact amount i had saved up
minus my one thousand dollar emergency
fund wow and i was like done it's
awesome did the trade loved it um
and then you know when you get off track
there was another morning that i'm i had
an opportunity to go to paris
and
i was like i can't go to paris but
um i i was being torn and then the next
morning i'm driving and i'm at this red
light and this sweet girl's like 5am
calls you and says dave i have an
opportunity to go to paris
and you are yelling at her like
no and i'm i'm sitting there at the red
light like dave knows
he
knows right now
then the next month a pandemic occurred
so i couldn't go anyways oh wow um but
you know it was just like the universe
is just kind of telling you when you're
intentional but when you're not you can
just you know i've had those months that
um i found a hundred dollars and then
it's just gone because some you know
it wasn't budgeted and it was spent yeah
yeah
way to go
way to go that's very cool i love that
that's a great story
oh so fun well we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you because for
sure that's the next chapter in your
story you're amazing
you are you're a force of nature kiddo
and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and get
somebody started because you never know
who's going to call you when you post
this debt free scream on your facebook
you never know
so well done i'm proud of you good stuff
good stuff well done thank you brittany
akron ohio 138 000 paid off in 47 months
making 57-74 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream okay three
two
one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
amazing this is how you get it done yeah
wow so great brittany congrats
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal and
today's question comes from kenzie in
utah my husband and i recently are
recently married and debt-free our
household income is a bit over a hundred
k we recognize
that we've been blessed to be a blessing
to others so we give it pretty
substantially out of our income we're
very committed to our church
and to giving resources to mission
efforts around the world as we talk
about buying a house in the next few
years we find it difficult to plan and
save when our heart
when when our heart is to give out of
our abundance
how do we find the good balance of
giving generously and planning for our
future that's a great question kenzie
what a great heart i was about to say
you sound amazing
um well
you know there's
there's kind of this this way of looking
at giving and two buckets i think
there's
a little bit more of kind of the
emotional side right you you hear of
something
you're at something someone mentions
some amazing non-profit or something
then you're like and you think okay i
just want to write a check i just want
to give i want to give i want to give
right there in the moment and then
there's a that spontaneous you know
factor then there's more of the planned
giving where you say okay i'm going to
really map out and look at the places
that i give
research them making sure that they are
legitimate which i'm sure you guys have
done with your church and your the
efforts that you're giving to with
missions around the world
but you're strategic on the amount too
that you say okay here's our budget and
here's what we're going to give to so
neither one necessarily is right or
wrong i think that leaning toward that
planned giving though kinsey is what i
would encourage you to do to say hey sit
down and actually put numbers to what's
going on because if you are budgeting
and you guys are debt-free so you're
going to be able to have more margin to
give which is amazing and to say okay we
want to give
i don't i don't care what it is 20 25
10 12 whatever you guys
feel like okay this is a good amount for
us to give
and plan that and then say okay out of
that and out of our budget how much do
we have to save for a down payment on a
home and then just map it out over the
next couple of years and see where that
gets you
because
both are great
saving up for a down payment on home is
awesome and giving generously is amazing
but you guys need to put a little bit
more detailed
um planning around it so that you can
make both happen instead of kind of just
it sounds a little bit on a whim some of
your giving
i would be a little bit more detailed
with it but i want to reframe
right now in your mind i want to reframe
your your paradigm on this kenzie
because right now in your mind the way
you describe this it's as if buying a
house feels selfish
and
counterproductive because that money
could be used for generosity
and it feels like these two things are
competing with each other and i don't
think that's a correct i don't think
that's real
what's real is buying a house will cause
you to become wealthier
than renting
if you rent your entire life you're
gonna have less money than if you buy a
house because rent goes up every year
when you buy a house the house goes up
and it becomes an asset and
you've stabilized and locked in your
housing cost it's not going up every
year
other than taxes and insurance might go
up but i mean the the cost of
the biggest cost you have is your
residence where you're where you're
going to stay you know and so
if you want to give more
the the best way to give more is to
build more wealth and stabilizing your
housing cost
is going to cause you to build more
wealth so they're not working against
each other long term
they might be this month
or they might be over a year
while you're trying to get into the
house and it's more expensive than where
you are now it might be right then but
over the course of 40 years
or 30 years
owning a house is going to cause you to
be able to be more generous
and so let's not let's not frame this
that these two things are competing
but if you pan back with a long enough
lens on this
you will see that buying a house is
going to cause you to be able to be more
generous i'll give you an example okay i
don't have a house payment rachel didn't
have a house payment
we can be more generous than somebody
that has rent
you know it's pretty simple so uh you
know you just don't have that big hairy
payment that most people got yeah you
know there's a couple thousand dollars
and most people's budget a month or 1500
bucks a month or whatever it is in most
people's budget that we don't have and
so you can that's money we've got that's
free to invest and or to give yes and
there's nothing unholy about planning
either
right because there's a little bit to
the mind of man plans his ways and the
lord directs the steps yep yeah
scripture says that so there's a there's
a level of being a good steward in this
too kenzie of you guys sitting down and
actually planning what's happening yeah
and you know i we plan our impulses
i mean it's we leave some we plan a line
item in the ramsey family foundation
budget annually to do some giving that
we don't know what it is yet
yeah and so we plan to but and then
we've got certain ministries and things
that we are supporting that we very
definitely lay down there but we leave
some margin in there for
things that are going to come our way
that we don't know yet yes and so that's
planning your impulse i mean it's kind
of funny but it's very true it's what we
do
good stuff everyone needs health
insurance if you're alive i assume
you're listening and that means you
you need health insurance everyone needs
health insurance healthy people high
deductible plans the best way
and if you need to know more about
health insurance a place to get the best
deal you can do that with one of our
health insurance elps they will shop
around and get you the best possible
deal and help you customize the plan to
your situation
what's the best type of plan for you hsa
ppo what's the best thing in your
situation they'll walk you through every
bit of that ramsey solutions dot com
slash health i'll plug you in with the
health insurance elp
charles is in greensboro north carolina
hey charles welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking the call
rachel um i was on the
building well seminar
uh last night and recovered inflation
high level kind of definition there had
a
question did you need deeper advice
budget wise like on certain categories i
mean
in our budget we're seeing food go up we
can eat out less is it a horrible time
to do some home improvements we've kind
of had plan obviously cost her up
our car replacement fund i've added to
that
um just given the cost of these cars
going up so when we get time to replace
it i'm going to have a little more saved
up
and then all that said as that kind of
eats into our budget
um like the internet is kind of the
first part there's certain areas of the
budget
or more advantageous to change than
others and then second part if i run out
of room anywhere else is it a horrible
time to adjust 401k
we don't have any debt but
just temporary during
short-term inflation
no i would adjust everything before i
adjusted that
uh all these other you know these home
improvements and car replacement funds
and all that stuff that's that's all
zeroed long before you touch your 401k
15 going in the 401k it's not the time
to step out of that
uh that's panning yeah not step out
or even even adjusting it down i
wouldn't i wouldn't no
but um i i think the main thing you need
to adjust for more than anything else is
your timing on a large purchase like
home improvement you may want to wait
and let building supplies and labor come
down
because they're both out of control
right now buying a used car
if you don't have to buy a car right now
it's a horrible time to buy a car
absolutely horrible
and uh if you don't have to this is not
the time to buy a car
um i'm not i mean i
i like cars and i'm not buying a car
right now
not a chance so i'm just going to let
these like because it's just it's just
moronic it's just out of control
i mean the used car market and it's all
about what we were talking about last
night it's a shortage yeah it's a
shortage of vehicles and so when the new
mark when the new factories get back up
to speed and they're dumping new on the
street like they used to and it's not a
nine month waiting period for a freaking
toyota truck how absurd
you know but when we get the people back
in the factory and we get those trucks
hitting the street again
or cars hitting the street again then
that's going to loosen up the used car
market but the used car market's being
driven up because the new car market has
microchips tremendous technology either
can't get the technology yeah so there's
going to be some adjustments but it's
not the time to do those two things i
would put those off the main place you
need to adjust your budget more than
anything else other than timing is just
the stuff that's the reality i mean it
costs more it costs more to fill your
gas tank right now yeah getting food and
gas rachel's right
your utility shouldn't have changed much
i'm not seeing those move much so you
just kind of look at what's the reality
of my budget and just map it out
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
welcome to the ramsey show rachel cruz
ramsey personality three times
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
we'll be talking about your work your
relationships your life your money
it's all intertwined right here
all day today we'll talk about you right
in front of you the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hannah is with us in jackson
mississippi hey hannah welcome to the
show
hey mr ramsey how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so i'm in baby step three i've paid
for my lungs and i'm working on my stage
good and i was wondering what would be
the what
should i focus on saving more on now
so retirement or
a house
that's a great question hannah where
where are you in life are you are you
married how old are you
um
what's your current status
i'm 27 i'm single and i live at home
with my mom i'm currently a teacher
and i don't foresee getting married
within the next five or ten years okay
and is buying a home something that you
that you want to do soon is it something
that you're looking at you're like i
would i would love my own place what you
know just the situation of your living
what do you want it is within um
probably a couple years not immediately
um i'm kind of wanting to stay home for
like a year or so we had a tragic event
that happened in our life recently
so i'm not trying to get out of the
house right now
okay is it just you and your mom
yes okay
then i think that's wise
especially when something big happens a
big change in life um
pausing and waiting i think is good to
to kind of grieve or go through that
process
before jumping into a big purchase like
a house so
for you knowing that it's there on the
horizon um i would i would map out and
look to see okay what kind of home would
you look at
what is something that you think you
would probably settle in what is that
going for right now even though i know
this could change in two years
and kind of just run some numbers to see
okay how much would it take to save up
ten percent of that would it take a year
would it take five years and map it out
because that also could give you
part of your answer because if it's
going to take you know three years to
save up for a down payment
then you may say okay i'm gonna just
start saving for that right now and hold
up from retirement because i know in
three years i probably will pull trigger
and you know go ahead and buy a home
uh but if you think okay i
you know don't even want to do that
right now you could go ahead and start
dipping into retirement and
putting 15 of your income there
and then pausing that down the road when
you think okay i really do want to save
up and pay for a home how old are you
i'm 27.
what's your income
i'm a teacher i make about um
two thousand a month
so i
bring home about twenty four thousand a
year
as soon as you finish your baby step
three i'd start saving for a house
okay right now i do have 31 000 in
savings
okay is that not your emergency fund
that's a big emergency fund
well you know kind of with the event
that happened my mom was able to get my
brother and i each enough
the money so after i paid off all my
debt
that's what i had left okay i would i
would separate that out between down
payment for a house an emergency fund
and you're done with baby step three
uh you just allocate some of that as
your emergency fund maybe i don't know
10 000 of it or something and you got 21
towards your down payment on your house
and then i would just work on your house
down payment for the next two years
after two years if you still think it's
going to be a while you could stop
saving for a house at that point and uh
but your income is so low that you're
going to want to go ahead and start
chipping away at this down payment thing
okay
and are you positioned where that income
is going to change pretty dramatically
quickly
uh well um that sounds awfully low for a
teacher
it is uh the state of this has one of
the lowest teacher salaries
um but the
i think the house is voting within the
next two days to increase it
and if that goes through my salary will
increase about about 6 000 a year
okay
all right yeah i'm i'm going to keep
working on that side of the equation as
well if i'm you but there's not a lot
you can do to actually make it happen
but
that's that's a concern
that's a concern because the average
household income in america today is 65
000
and you're sitting at 24 take-home pay
which means you're making about 30. and
so um you know that that's what you're
looking at so yeah i'm gonna go ahead
and start piling up money out of this i
mean if you if you were making 150
thousand dollars a year or something we
might say
you could wait a little later to start
saving for your down payment because you
don't know when you're going to buy but
you've got enough
you know it's going to be a big enough
hill to climb for you to go ahead and
start working on it now
good question thank you for joining us
elizabeth is in boise idaho hi elizabeth
how are you
i'm good thank you good i have a
question about
um reverse mortgages
do you have an opinion on those they
suck
they suck okay horrible
well i have
a lot of home repairs i'm in my middle
70s
and
because my home is older
there are a lot of repairs and
renovations that just seem to be piling
up and so
for fifty thousand dollars i could
probably
have this house and you don't have any
money
well i
i have a
fairly decent pension and
stream but
it pretty much gets eaten up with
medical
but you don't have you don't have any
money you don't have a doubt you don't
have any savings
well i have a roth that would pretty
much pay for a project that is
how much is it how much is in your roth
25 000. that's your only nest egg
right my financial guy didn't want me to
use that because that would be my you
don't have any money emergency i have
about ten thousand dollars in savings is
all and how much is your pension a year
i get about sixty
a year
including how long have you lived in
this house
20 years
so could you be more specific about why
reverse mortgages stuck
yeah the the foreclosure rate on them is
tenfold the normal mortgages
and the interest rates are unusually
high and the fees that are built into
them are
predatory
uh and it is an industry that feeds on
the elderly
and it's it's a predatory industry it's
horrible
uh
the and you are going systematically
into debt
right and you can't borrow that much
anyway so what's this house worth
about 650 000.
i'm going to give you some heartbreaking
advice
that you're not going to
like if you were my sister i'm 61
i would tell my sister i love you
sell your house
i wouldn't repair it i would sell it i
would move into a nice
modern
400 000 house and bank 250.
that's what i would do
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money
how would you feel if you knew you were
going to retire
with dignity that you'd leave an
inheritance to your family
that'd be freeing wouldn't it and the
truth is you can have that kind of life
you actually can become wealthy you can
become
a millionaire
this year take control of your money and
start building lasting wealth with the
best year ever bundle in this bundle you
get financial peace university and the
premium version of every dollar
two resources that'll help you take back
control
of your largest wealth building tool
your income
and you'll use a copy of the brand new
book baby steps millionaires to learn
the right way to invest to get to a
million dollar net worth
and uh
what you do right now is impacting the
kind of life you're going to have later
so the good news is you get to decide
what that life looks like get the best
year ever bundle going to ramsey
solutions dot com slash best that's
ramsey solutions dot com slash
best
this is the ramsey show rachel cruz is
with me today we're talking about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five mark is in miami hey mark welcome
to the show
hi good afternoon mr ramsey thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
um so i have a question regarding
my and my wife's student loan situation
the best way to
to approach it we do have a large amount
of student loan debt
it's just around 400 thousand dollars
combined good lord who's the doctor
well i'm an attorney
and i've been out of school for about
six years my wife i just graduated from
nurse anesthesia school
this december and so
i have approximately 250 000 and she has
about 150 000 please tell me both of you
have wonderful incomes as a result of
this
uh i think we do we have a combined um
income
of just under three hundred thousand two
hundred and ninety five good okay all
right we're on our way and hers is
probably going up from there
maybe it may be faster than yours
depending on what kind of law you're
practicing
definitely faster than mine yeah
wow and so oh very good well no i was
going to say i mean that's that's part
of the the the ray of hope and the story
with 400 000 in debt though is that your
income it's a big shovel you guys have a
big hole but you got a big shovel
and so
being able to attack
the debt with this you guys will make
good progress um
in a much faster obviously period of
time then you know the average household
income in america is 65 000 right
yeah no we're definitely in a good spot
and i guess i know but my point is what
if you lived on that
that is a good point yeah and and that
would be like 200 000
a year towards your student loans and
you'd be done in two years
yeah
so that's a very good point a very good
way to look at it
um that yao didn't sound real convincing
it is but you signed up for this trip
brother
yeah no you're what's the other factor
mark i i interrupted you you were about
to talk and i interrupted earlier so is
there another factor um
yeah it was just um how to how you all
would uh recommend
approaching it because we have two sets
of of loans and as you all are aware
with these loans are individual per
semester or per section of the school so
they all have different principal
amounts and different interest rates and
is there a way that you would recommend
approaching that as opposed to i would
just listen to the smallest smallest
loan to largest loan
but more than anything what you guys
need to do is you need to really say to
yourself
do we want to screw around with this
mess
for 10 years
or do we want to go scorched earth
where our lawyer and doctor friends
think we've lost our minds
and be done with this fast
i will tell you that your probability of
getting out of debt and becoming
extremely prosperous
increases by every year you cut off this
get out of that plan
understood so i would be i would be if
if i woke up in years there's no one i
know
i'd be band-aid off rip it off guy i'd
be
i'm i'm we're doing nothing we're not
going on vacation we're broke
yeah we're a lawyer and a doc nurse
anesthesiologist but but we're broke we
are 400
000 in debt we are broke
and this is the way i start talking to
myself and go no we're not buying a car
we're broke
no we're not going on vacation we're
broke
no we're not going out to eat we're
broke we're going to live on 65 000. i
don't really care what your stupid
friends think
i'm getting out of debt because dude if
you get rid of this you know what you
got you got a 300 000 going on a 400 000
income with no debt you're gonna be so
stinking wealthy you're gonna be able to
do anything you wanna do the rest of
your life
that's how i would approve that that's
how i'd approach no no i i appreciate it
yeah looking at the
the long game looking at the end yeah
the end game and
the problem is in your world it is so
in
lawyer world doctor world nurse world it
is so normal
to walk around for a decade with this
backache
when you make more money than 98 of
people out there walking around
and they just they they i got to tell
you man
i meet broke attorneys all the time
and they just
because they've normalized it that this
is okay
and when other people in other
industries look at it and they just
freak out going oh my god he's got you
know but in your world it's just
normalized and you if you're not careful
man because you're running around with a
bunch of people who on the financial
side of things are stupid
they're stupid
uh and and they're keeping these loans
around and they it's just a way of life
is just part of it and they walk around
with this backache man you ought to get
you ought to get fired up and i want you
to be a weird lawyer
and it would be it would be interesting
mark the exercise of
getting just a investment calculator out
and saying what if we invested our
student loan payments so say we had so
just say you did this plan right you
went two years scorched earth paid it
all off and then you took what is your
student loan payment every month and put
it in an investment calculator and just
play it out it's tens of millions of
people play it out and just see okay
what what could it look this is what
it's costing you and for for a
short-term sacrifice for what you guys
could do i mean it's it's amazing and i
think what would be hard too
is with this income
the pain probably isn't really there
it's not like
so so you have to almost create this
urgency even though you're not feeling
it like i even hear it in your voice
mark there's not an urgency there's not
an urgentness i'm more scared for you
than you are
so you so
fine find the why what is it what is it
about this debt
that's going to piss you off and say man
if we had just paid it off earlier what
would we have done right like like run
all the scenarios look at all of it
because you could you guys could have a
lot of money which is awesome because
you can do a lot of fun stuff
help a lot of people
your life could really be different if
you just said hey what if we got rid of
this debt this massive the difference in
what i'm talking about and what you're
thinking about is 10 million dollars
that's the difference
you need to get that in your dadgum head
man
because you're gonna you're gonna screw
around with this thing and you're gonna
normalize it and you're gonna keep your
stupid law your lifestyle while you're
broke
and you're gonna take 10 years to do
this versus two years to do this and the
difference is ten million dollars
that's what that's what's going to cost
you and what the money should have done
that's fabulous income should have
become
what you could have become but you've
got to pay a price to get there and
here's the interesting thing you do have
you and your wife have the unusual
ability to
delay pleasure for a greater gain we
know this because you went to law school
that's while everybody else was finished
their undergrad went to work but you
delayed pleasure for a greater gain she
went to anesthesia school you delayed
pleasure for a greater gain and that's
all i'm trying to get you to do is apply
that that level of maturity to the math
on this money situation
and if you do that
dude but if you get dr itis
where you come out and have to look like
you're a dead young rich lawyer when
you're broke in miami may not help
either you're not living in des moines
there's a there's a flashiness to miami
which is fun but the culture too you're
going to push back you're going to get a
lot of stay out of miami beach
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the debt-free line
shanae is with us in laurel maryland
with her debt-free story hey shanae
what's up
oh nothing i'm fighting to be talking to
you dave
too you too how much debt have you paid
off kiddo
a little over ninety three thousand
dollars good for you how long did that
take
two years and ten months all right i
like it and what was your range of
income during that time
well i started off at about 64 and i
finished at 170 000.
what happened to your income
i um i started my own business and uh it
did really well apparently
what are you doing shanae what is it
what's the business um i actually am an
herbalist i sell herbal tea but i kind
of do it with a hip-hop flair and so i
just
got a lot of other interested people and
just really worked on my marketing
boom i love it hip-hop herbal tea is big
in maryland
oh my gosh girl that's awesome
i like it this is very cool good for you
so what kind of debt was the 93
um well 73 626 was student loans um
and about 11 000 was a car loan and then
the rest were some credit cards
wow
so what happened uh what happened three
years ago that woke you up
uh well honestly um
i was sharing a bank account with
someone and they had a judgment against
them and they
they took the money out of my account
and so
i was really in a rut i didn't have any
money for anything and i realized man
this really sucks
um and so i got more serious about
paying off my debt
and just realizing how much more money i
would have if i wasn't putting out so
much to debt and other bills that it was
i was just working to pay bills like i
didn't have anything at the end of it to
the point where when i had a mistake i
lost all the money i didn't have
anything so
um it was like a scare but i got serious
about my finances how did you find us
um
the um total money makeover i used it to
pay off my very first car after college
um and then i guess i chucked it away
dave
and i got more debt and didn't use it
for um paying off my student loans
but it worked to pay off my first car so
i said let me try it again even though
i'm worse off now it should work
okay good it's awesome good good for you
how old are you can i ask i just turned
34. congratulations well done that's
amazing absolutely incredible and from
start i mean like what happened to you
three years ago and your bank accounts
wiped out i mean all of it i'm like
i mean you started from the ground up i
mean you really you've done this it's
amazing and started your own business i
mean it's incredible you have an amazing
story
oh thank you
you put god first
nothing you can't do yeah that's right
that's good for you good for you well
done
okay now that you've now that you've
done all of this will you will you go
back in debt again
oh i i i need therapy i've got ppsd
[Laughter]
i need like a you need some good herbal
tea
i know a girl by the way
[Laughter]
she can hook you up
yes
oh man i'm done i'm done with that now
forever and you're done combining
accounts with people that hadn't got
their crap together
yes i'm i'm more than done with that
i got a feeling there's a story there
oh my gosh so what was the hardest part
shanae for you as you're doing this i
mean you started from basically nothing
like you said with your story at 31
and you and you did it so what during
the journey what was what was the
toughest part
a lot of it was just kind of feeling
like i would never get out of debt i
think that was like the most crushing
blow
um it's just feeling like i really
screwed up and there was no way out
but um there is a way out you just got
to work the plan
and work your hardest to make more money
and be diligent about paying off your
debt um but in those dark moments man
it's like oh you have nothing to spend
you have only you've got you learn to be
grateful for having your car note paid
and your rent paid and having food in
your refrigerator you know you really
learn to be appreciative of those
moments and not thinking about man all
the extras and what everyone else is
doing on social media and where your
friends are going um you can really feel
like you're left out and not doing the
right thing but if you work the plan
you'll realize that in the end
it all works out for the good a heart of
gratitude too which is a big piece of
this that you have well i like that you
decided this answer to your equation was
entrepreneurism i mean you went after it
um yeah i did i i
you know
you've been working you don't
accidentally do this
no you you've got to work hard even on
the days when you make no money on the
days you lose money you gotta work like
you made a million dollars there you go
definitely work yeah i can tell i can
tell you've been busting it i mean 170
000 is a lot of tea
yes and taxes yeah
t in taxes
boston tea party is on the horizon i'm
just saying
wow look at you yeah look at you well
done okay so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
um
you got to make more money
you got to do what you got to do whether
that means getting more skills whether
it means finding a side hustle um
whatever you got to do you got to make
more money because once you get to my
point there was nothing else to cut
you know so i had to make more money to
pay off those significant student loans
they weren't going down
some of the best businesses ever in the
world were started by someone that had
to get something going
yeah you know and you're just you're
you're amazing i and i got a feeling
this is going nowhere but up you're
you're like a force of nature i'm proud
of you well done oh thank you thank you
so much well done well done well we've
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
that we'll send to you because that's
definitely the next
chapter in your story for sure how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too i think
you'll be in
be in that list of people that did this
thing and also send you a copy of the
total money makeover that you can give
to somebody so they can pay off their
car loan and 11 years later decide to do
it all again
yes
hopefully they'll be better than me be
smarter don't fall off the wagon again
sinead don't make me come to maryland
no i can't do it i can't i can't do it
i love it i'm proud of you you're
something else very well done all right
it's shanae and laurel maryland 93 000
paid off in two years and 10 months
making 64 to 170. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
i'm debt-free
[Music]
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
oh my goodness that's fabulous
i love it i love hearing people's
stories because either the equation of
cutting expenses is a big part of their
story or making the income because some
people are like oh gosh we're spending
like nuts we just cut nothing and we had
all this money we were able to throw out
the debt pay it off and for her she's
like i cut everything but i had to make
more money you know that it's
interesting which part of the equation
people uh gravitate towards or for their
specific situation what they need to do
the most of well if not both but
we don't know what happened with that
account
that that got messed up but what we do
know is is that there's a whole lot more
happen with shanae and there usually is
than simply going oh i think i need to
pay off some debt her whole
way of looking at life was transformed
yeah it had to be i mean she had to get
different people in her life and get the
wrong people out of her life the right
people into her life
she changed her way of looking at her
career and her income boom here comes
this business out of these ideas this is
a whole abundance idea rather than
scarcity thing which is exactly what
you're talking about there and you talk
about that and know yourself know your
money as a matter of fact yeah but uh
she transformed
and then
and
as the debt was leaving and it was
necessary for her to do that for the
debt to leave it was a whole lot more
than simply
i'm going to change the way i handle my
money that's right her whole life turned
over yeah and in a good way and that
happens so often and it runs parallel
that's why we hear people losing weight
while they're getting out of debt we
hear people whose marriages are healed
while they're getting out of debt and
it's not that that getting out of debt
is magical it's just so you're you're
affecting your relationships and your
behavior so positively
all at one time and if there's this
massive massive move in your life
good stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at
825-5225
anastasia is with us in new york city hi
anastasia how are you
hi dave and rachel i'm better than i
deserve cool how can we help
so me and my husband we're huge fans
currently we are refinancing our 30 year
to a 15 year
we've been working with a lender we
signed an initial disclosure with them
in december they got back to us with a
2.75
interest
our current bank is offering us the same
or possibly a lower rate but we also get
a fema tax which uh adds up to about
seven thousand dollars my question is
should we
um is it moral to stop working with the
bank that we've been working with since
december
and stay with our current bank and get
that ball rolling or should we
um not take the free money for some
reason what is the free money from your
bank i didn't understand
fema is a in new york state there's like
a transfer tax so if we would to stay
with our current bank we don't have to
pay the 7 000 transfer tax
that excuse me we would have to pay with
any other bank
so to record the mortgage
it's like a transfer tax you're not
transferring anything transfer taxes if
you sell the house
are you sure
yes i'm sure because we've also talked
to another lender who was trying to get
us to schema but he said that our bank
is slow on it and that it would take 12
weeks to close
and we don't know what the rates would
be like in 12 weeks and to lock in the
rates for 12 weeks might not make sense
to save those so another lender can
offer to pay the transfer tax is that
what you're saying
yes but they're also not going to pay
all of them so the best the best option
that we've come to after talking to
three lenders is either
staying with our current bank and doing
the whole application and everything
from start
or to keep going with the banks that
we're going with that we started going
with your current bank really shouldn't
have a bunch of application and stuff
they've already got a loan on the books
right
who's your current who's your current
lender
our current lender is mnt bank okay
all right and so it's seven thousand
dollars cheaper for the same mortgage
but you have to start the process over
yes so and is it moral to like to stop
now before we locked in the rate that
we're talking about sure it is yeah you
haven't closed one you haven't signed a
contract with a mortgage company you
just were you're trying to get a loan
worked and you got a better deal
that's not right but then like
can they charge us attorney fees or
anything we haven't paid anything no
no you don't you didn't sign a contract
they just are you just running a loan
application and you decide you didn't
want the loan
right we find an initial disclosure
that's fine disclosure just means they
disclose to you what the rates are
right that's all that means that's
that's not a that's not a contract on
your part that says i'm contracting to
close i mean they're going to be
disappointed they're gonna lose a deal
but
um you're just shopping loans and you
found a better loan that's all it is i
mean there's no there's not a moral
dilemma here
okay
um and i do have another question i
would try to i would try to give the uh
current bank the opportunity to match it
but i don't think they can
no they can't match a sema loan like
that's seven thousand dollars off of our
closing yeah i know that's why i doubt
they can but
i just go look this is this is what's
driving this you know we weren't mad at
you we were ready to do this but seven
thousand bucks i mean what would you do
and they gotta go well yeah that's what
you should do i i honestly i'm not
familiar enough with new york
uh law real estate law to know what
you're talking about it's a very the
thing you're describing is very unusual
on a national level
uh but hey it's new york i mean of
course it's unusual it's like california
it's like saying it's california weird
yes of course it's weird you know but
i mean weird laws weird laws in both
states uh and um taxes too
taxes you know that's it and this is yet
another tax is where i feel like a fee
yeah i don't know of another state where
you when you refinance your mortgage you
get tagged
by this by attacks i didn't know i've
never heard of that in any state i
didn't know that happened so i'm
learning something in this call but
doing this show for 30 years i learned
something almost every day
steve is in chandler arizona hey steve
what's up
hey dave and rachel nice to talk to you
guys you too i'm in baby step seven and
i have about yeah thank you um so i have
about uh sixty five thousand dollars to
uh that i got from an inheritance
and i fully funded my roth for 21 and
20.
uh what should i do with the 65k
that's a fun question steve what do you
do with 65 000. i'm babystep seven
well when you're at this point i mean to
the rachel cruz travel fund and here's
the address
that's right i can give you lots of
destinations you can go no
i mean it's you know at this point you
really do three things with money you
give it you save it you spend it and so
with this amount i mean i would do that
i would i would take a little bit you
could be generous with some of it i
think some of it you
you put away maybe you take some of it
out and say hey for for retirement next
year i can i can stock some this way or
maybe you're
um i don't know if you have just even a
just a mutual fund to open outside of
retirement you can throw some in
um but saving a little of it and then i
think enjoying some of it where did it
come from
it's been an inheritance yes but like a
family member
yes
and where are you married kids
no no no wife no ex-wife no kids okay
yeah so i mean that i mean if i were you
steve that's what i would do you have no
payments i would i would give some of
this away i would
put some away for you know the next year
or two if there's something you're
saving towards and then you can enjoy
some of it
excellent exactly that's what uh
sharon and i do we get uh lump sum
checks from publishers occasionally from
you know some of the books are still
paying royalties over the years and that
kind of thing
even even old financial piece i still
get a check on it from the 90s
occasionally and uh so when we get a
check in what we're what we have the
practice of doing is
we're always gonna we take percentages
and we say all right we're gonna tithe
on it we're evangelical christians so
we're gonna give a tenth and then we're
going to do another chunk of giving a
percentage we're going to enjoy a
percentage or spend it on something
guilt-free
and we're going to uh invest a
percentage
and of course in our case we have to set
aside you don't own an inheritance but
we have set aside 40 for taxes
so before we even start talking about
this but that's you know that that you
just we teach people that um high net
worth people when they get lump sums
like that to always just give every
dollar an assignment and it helps if
you're going to be doing this regularly
and hopefully you're not going to be
getting inheritance regularly that would
mean
bad things for your family but um but i
mean the uh if you're going to get a
lump sum regularly folks you just apply
set yourself up a formula so i've
already got a formula set that you know
when i get a check in it's like that
percentage goes there that percentage
goes there
so if it's you know no matter what the
amount of the check is it's still laid
out okay so that's a good point you may
you said yeah you're not get taxed on
this inheritance what it like there
there's no tax on inheritance right uh
but the gift tax there's gift tax like
what like the difficulty there would be
a gift tax if somebody gave you money
yes yeah yes if there was something
that's on the giver not on the receiver
the giver yes okay so they're still not
taxable from an income tax yep
perspective and inheritances is there
like a lot what is what's around that to
protect an inheritance that it's not
well the
there is a they don't see it as income
there is a tax on an inheritance tax but
it's up if you're over 20 million
dollars
on the estate there's an estate tax
federal estate tax now local
uh
most states have a probate tax as well
when the will is probated
and that sometimes can be as much as
like five percent which is pretty
substantial sometimes so
uh but but again that when the estate is
settled that money is paid out of the
estate so when you send a check to the
person who inherited money it's already
knitted out it's already done yeah so
you still don't have any taxes yeah in
that case
even the federal estate tax you don't
have it but um but it does come out of
the estate
uh before you or should come out of the
estate before you distribute to the
heirs um but land is different though
right because i but when you inherit the
values you have to pay the tax on it the
value of the land is there same thing
okay same thing to stock any of it it's
um what's the whole thing i mean i feel
like i know about family members that
have inherited land and they can't keep
the land because they can't pay the
taxes on it because it's too much value
but that's different than huge value
that's indifferent and an inheritance
that's good it is inherently well they
can't pay they can't if it's if it's
like a huge family ranch like these huge
ranches are being broken up family farms
because they're worth over 20 million oh
but it's let's be over that 20 million
taxes can be as much as 55 on that
so because we must punish rich people it
is a rule in america
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host rachel cruz
ramsey personality best-selling author
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
we talk about your work your life your
relationships
your
money all right here thanks for joining
us it's a free call triple eight eight
two five five
chris is with us in columbus ohio hi
chris welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and rachel thanks for taking my
call sure um i was i was calling in to
ask about saving up for my son's future
so my wife and i are on currently on
baby steps four five and six
and in the fall we opened up a 5 29 for
our nine month old son fun good for you
way to go
papa well thank you um and we actually
found out over the holidays that my
grandma wants to contribute 25 000
uh to my son's future
um she wasn't she's not super specific
with how she wants that money to be
saved for him and so you know we have
the 529 account and we were wondering if
the best thing to do would be to just
throw into the account we already have
or is there another type of account that
would be like a non-retirement
investment account or something that
would give us more control and more
freedom in case you know maybe he
doesn't um go to college and just that
we have a little bit more ability to do
things with it uh just because we want
to make you know the wisest decision
with such a big gift yeah that is so
cool that's good so cool she needs to be
sure she writes that in two different
checks one to you and one to your wife
so she doesn't get into gift tax okay
yes all right good now once we're doing
that you yeah you can drop it into the
529 if you want that's not a problem um
and it would
it would probably mean that you're done
with college then and you can save for
other things if you want to outside the
529 that's assuming your particular 529
allows a contribution of that large in
one year some of them have a 10 000
limit some of them have a 50 000 limit
so you'd have to check on yours and see
what you're doing there
now what you can do
and before the 529s and the esa's were
out there
when rachel was a wet
um
we were not able we didn't have those
types of college funds for our kids they
weren't available and so the way you
saved for college in those days was you
just opened a mutual fund in the kid's
name
it's called an uttama an utma uniform
transfer to miners act which by the way
if you open a bank account for the
little kid it's the same thing because
miners cannot conduct business they
can't do contract in any state and so
the parent is always doing it you put
the kid's name on it but it has a
custodian
and you're the custodian of the account
now what that does is
that by being in the kid's name
it won't have any income tax on it until
the until the account makes enough in
one year to break through standard
deductions
okay and so
um
you know if it breaks through standard
deductions it may have a little bit of
tax on it but it'll grow largely
tax-free for a long time 25 000 won't
make enough
for many years until it grows to
probably double that to where you
actually get into paying any taxes on it
so that's what we used we just had
mutual funds in the kids names
and uh you know and you know and when
they got ready to go to school that
money was there we could use it for
school now those are controlled until
the child is 21
when they're 21 it's their money
and you don't have any control over that
technically speaking
now you know we're kind of old-fashioned
dinosaur parents and so if they're doing
heroin we'll just hide the money screw
it you know sue me
right but uh but that's like that's kind
of like stealing their money technically
you know but i would steal it before i'd
give it to them if they're doing heroin
so um because i put it in there in the
first place right so
deal with it but yeah but that
technically speaking you know if they if
they're off the ranch if they've lost
their dadgum mines at 21 it's still
their money
yeah yeah that was the other you know
concern that we had we wanted to make
sure you know we obviously don't plan on
that kind of thing happening but we
wanted to make sure that
we didn't know if there's a way that we
there's an account that we could have
that made sure that we had control over
it so it was used for a wise investment
no wait no way to control it past 21 if
you put it in his name okay
okay i'm thinking this out loud so i
could be totally wrong on this so what
would be the thing if they if chris just
took that 25 000
put it in a mutual fund in his name and
then paid out the kids college that'd be
fine but all of the all the income on
the mutual fund is going to be taxes
it's going to be taxed when they take it
out it's going to be taxable well it
depends on the if the mutual fund is a
low turnover it won't be taxed now yeah
but if it's a high turnover regular
mutual fund you're going to pay taxes on
it
so the tax position is substantial over
20 years worse versus the up yeah yeah i
just you know i i i started with the
assumption that i was just going to make
my kids behave
and so we always laughed and said we put
a bunch of money in their names so let
the beatings begin i mean it's like
you know
counseling yeah there you go this is
what this is
pay for your counseling bill later but
yeah but the uh
[Laughter]
but i mean that's
it was a joke and you seemed so hardcore
i'm like yo we're not intense parents
everyone's like oh my god that was a
joke that wasn't like growing up his day
from his kid i was like he was way more
chill at home than he is on the radio it
was a chocolate big game you caught the
big you were not abused as a child calm
down
i know
but yeah the point being that you know a
lot of people are afraid of what's gonna
happen with a kid when they grow up and
that's a that is a normal thing that or
what's gonna happen to college that's a
big conversation what does a four-year
degree look like
in 18 years yeah do you know what i mean
like that that whole industry is
shifting so much
higher ed because of all things but i'm
like that and that's a has i mean we
have a six four and
two-year-old and we did you know we have
529s for all of them but i do think that
in the back of my head where i'm like
man what like
i don't know what if because
it's it's a you kind of do bank when you
do an esa or a 529 yep it's for the
education world i mean that's what it is
so they're well they can go to trade
schools is there any time you would
shift your advice you didn't go to trade
school on it to do it yeah yeah but and
here's the other thing if if the whole
thing completely unraveled you just take
the money out you just gotta pay taxes
on it
it's got a penalty in taxes it's like
you don't use it for education if you
don't use it for education you just take
it out you got it you got taxes and a
penalty what's that is that you know
cash not a retirement account early but
that's like yeah the whole world melted
down there's no education options yeah
which won't happen of course there's
going to be education options so the
other thing is is that your brain is the
conspiracy blog i read the other day oh
you were crazy
but this world's going to be in 18 years
you read a conspiracy block i can't
believe that rachel
she's queen for those of you don't know
she's queen of all conspiracy theories
this is our whole thanksgiving dinner
nothing is as it seems we've had we've
had to finally just go we can't do any
more rachel stop
because she just destroys all family
trees part of the new world order or
something i don't know i actually sit on
this i actually sit on the board in the
illuminati and so that that according to
rachel oh my god
oh
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
a lot of you have been filing your
income taxes with the same software for
many years but you're sick and tired of
all the add-on fees and you're sick and
tired of all the upsells where they're
trying to sell you into something else
all the time
the reality is is that for most people
it's not free
they say they're free but by the time
you get into it it's simply not free
and by the time you realize you don't
meet the quote free criteria you've
already put in too much time to start
over somewhere else and you just pay up
and they're making a killing off of you
we think you deserve better that's why
we're offering ramsey smart tax
you can file your taxes online
without paying more than you'd expect
ramsey smart tax includes every form you
need with no hidden fees
no upsells no surprises we're not going
to lead you into something else
we even have a promo code right now so
you can file your federal taxes for free
and if you'd prefer to have a priority
support and extended audit protection
you can go to our premium version for
just twenty dollars
if you're ready to ditch the other guys
for surprising you with fees
and it's really save money on your taxes
time to have something clean simple
predictable
ramsey solutions dot com smart tax
get started right now ramsay solutions
dot com
slash smart tax zack is with us in
franklin tennessee right here in our
neighborhood how are you zach
i'm good sir thank you very much
thank you for having me sure yesterday
uh my wife and i had a uh the privilege
of attending your event last night one
thank you for the wisdom that you
provided for that thank you um
but we are starting uh our first
business together this year we're set to
open up in just a couple short weeks
here good and
we wanted to know
if we should
budget off of our savings that we
already have in our bank
or if we should
plan to budget off of what we're going
to make from the business this year
your personal budget at home
yes sir
okay so
our income from the business if you
don't have income do you have do you
have other jobs other than this business
uh no sir we left our w-2 jobs to do
this whoa
okay how much do you have in savings
we have a 175 000
wow good for you
okay what's it take for you to operate
your household a month how much do you
need a month what's your burn rate it's
85 000
a year
yes sir not a month okay all right
no so it takes seven thousand dollars a
month to operate your house
uh
sounds high um
well we have three kids in preschool
um that takes up quite a bit
um our mortgage is
about 22
of that um
so we basically budgeted everything
on percentage base around that and those
are the two big things well what are you
having what kind of a business are you
opening
we have a recreational accelerating
business recreational what
accenting
axe throwing
yes
rachel got it yes
it's a thing to do i know i don't know
what it is it's a thing like people yeah
i'm just i'm just kind of aghast you
quit your jobs to do this until you had
it open and going oh my gosh
well have you well well did y'all have
prior experience zach like have you guys
been running this like what what's a
little bit of the story and where is it
story yeah
we are in franklin um we we opened up a
mobile axe during a trailer last year
and this is our stepping stone into
the full-time storefront
um
we just wanted to know like the
psychology kind of behind
uh knowing that we got money to take
care of us this year or if we should
really press
uh doing well with the business okay so
what do you what are you projecting
revenues or net profits that you could
take out of the business
net profit that we could um again the
projections but they are they range from
300 to 400 this year
and then double that next year
thousand dollars
yes sir
with recreational axe throwing
it's a bigger thing than i knew
i knew it existed i knew it existed yeah
my gosh i mean this is like should we
should we are we in the wrong business
apparently i am
i mean that's a yeah i don't know i mean
i don't know and zach is these are these
how are you getting these numbers though
because you you guys obviously had you
said you did one like kind of in a
trailer and you're just saying hey if we
had this amount of people like
do you know what i mean like what's um
yeah this has been in the works for a
couple years um
the this you know the sport if i can
call it that is been around for a
handful of years and we've we've gone to
other places talked to other people who
have been involved um the numbers work
really well for where we are
and
there's multiple in nashville there's
other locations i mean i've seen it and
i knew it was you know sometimes a part
of a a sports bar or a thing or
something like that i mean i've seen
these things but i just had no idea that
they were doing this kind of money that
i'm just i'm that's awesome i'm i i sure
hope that's a great you do that that's
amazing okay so if you're gonna do that
you won't need any of your savings right
yeah i guess i just didn't want to take
that we're taking that risk of this
first year
if you make 300 000 dude why would you
use any of your savings when you only
need 85 to live on
i guess it was just making sure that we
can um
you know those projections are just
projections to a certain degree until we
actually if you don't hit your
projections you might have to use some
of your savings
okay but if you hit one third of your
projections you won't have any issue
if you're 70 off on your projections
you're still okay
does that sound good you're not you're
talking about profit right not revenue
yes sir that's correct
okay yeah i mean if you're 70 off you're
gonna make a hundred thousand dollars
you understand
yes sir so if you don't it's your
projections
dip into your savings
but if you don't hit your projections
you've got other stuff going on because
you're going to be dramatically
uh i don't want to use the wrong
metaphor here you you dramatically
missed the bullseye i mean what would
you what would you say with axe throwing
i don't know but yeah
yeah i mean you
wow oh it was great zach i mean that's
amazing i gotta go try it it's right
here in our neighborhood i get james
let's go x throwing you want to
he's roping james in now come on man
let's go
make sure this guy make sure this guy's
business okay so so
here's a just like let's play it out the
other way for exactly let's say it does
nothing exactly so let's see if you take
out 85 000 in a year out of 175 yep and
and and to the point
you know
when people go because i mean there's
people saying that this call they're
thinking hey yeah i'm wanting to do a
thing and obviously i'm i'm assuming
they
they're not doing it out of the trailer
anymore i think he said our stepping
stone so so if you go in and lease like
a storefront that's what i think he said
something about storefront so
i mean you're locked into like a year
contract i mean like probably a five
year so so people that want to do
something not ax throwing necessarily
but get into a business and want to kind
of make the jump
what are a couple of things how can they
do that wisely well this guy did this
extremely wisely because he what he's
got this big fat savings over here
and if his projections are way off
he's still okay yes you know he and i i
don't know what they were making what
kind of w-2 jobs they walked away from
but um and
apparently
those projections are not based on wet
finger in the air they're based on
an upgrade from the former mobile
business right right the mobile axe
throwing business um
[Laughter]
things you don't get on other shows but
um
but i mean you know it's it so if you
can start your business part time before
you quit your w-2 which is what they did
essentially
and
proof text it meaning get it moving in
the marketplace you're putting your foot
off one foot on the dock one foot in the
boat you're testing it out yeah and then
once you feel like okay we're making
these projections where we when we make
the steps
and they make that step and it's not
that big a step then i mean let's just
pretend that he made 150
mobile
and they figure they can double it right
okay um that's not unreasonable totally
yeah and
they got a lot of
leeway to be wrong and still be okay yes
that's the key you know they're not
gonna make less than they used to make
well i don't know what they used to make
we didn't ask them but i mean they're
not gonna that 175 pad there that's a
big deal yep it's a big deal
wow
congrats zach
man i'm coming to visit i want to try it
yeah that's cool man wow
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage jason
and heather are with us hey guys how are
you hi i'm so excited to be here well
we're honored to have you guys welcome
welcome where do you live
we live in winston-salem north carolina
oh i love winston-salem a great town
thanks for visiting us guys good to have
you how much debt have you paid off we
paid off a hundred six thousand dollars
in three and a half years
yeah and your range of income during
that time we started at thirty thousand
dollars and ended at a hundred thousand
dollars wow
very cool what happened there
well we actually we started when we were
not yet married about four years ago we
knew we were getting serious we were
dating and we took fpu the beginning of
2018 yeah and um and so we had separate
thirty thousand dollar income which
doesn't really affect that but part of
it was he had a lot of credit card debt
and i was really concerned about that
and i was a single mom of three teen i
have three teenagers and i just wanted
to make sure we were moving in the right
direction good that's very wise good for
you what kind of debt was 106 all credit
cards uh we had 35 in credit card 38 was
a heloc we had 10 000 in medical
and then 23 to the kg irs
good for you guys cool what do y'all do
for a living
i am actually i started out in the
banking industry and then went back into
home maintenance i'm a handyman actually
that's a very good job very good career
and i was i was a residential cleaner
and i actually transitioned into just
staying at home oh wow awesome good okay
so the handyman business is good then
yeah excellent good for you guys very
cool so uh
the whole thing of the whole thing of
eula you're dating you look up and see
some credit card debt that's what gets
this whole thing started
yeah i mean we both i think we're
wanting something
similar but we have we have quite a
journey i mean our journey didn't really
get started until we got married the end
of 2018 and i'll let jason share a
little bit about that we got married um
9 9 18. and that's really when our story
began
and our walk began
um
i have a problem with alcohol
and i'd been drinking and not able to
quit
because i drink alcoholically
and i had lied to heather if you were
walking on this planet i was telling you
i was sober but i could not stop
60 days into our marriage
we separated wow
left the home wow december 2nd 2018 is
my sobriety date
but the most important date besides my
birthday
is 12 12 18.
which is the day i gave my life to jesus
christ wow
this is a story right here man yeah it's
been a journey wow so it was just for my
safety necessary for me to leave sure um
very hard to do i mean yeah just think
what do people think after you've only
been married two months it doesn't
matter what people think if you are in a
mess you got to get away from the mess
yeah and because he had deceived me so
much and i had to leave under you know
to keep myself safe i didn't see him for
five months and i wanted things to work
out but i wasn't like
sure said that it was sure we would have
to um
but he
in the meanwhile um
it was a lot of white knuckle 12-step
program
and then i got involved with a men's
ministry marked men for christ and
to have christian men
surround you to know you
to speak truth over you on how the lord
sees you as his child
and to feel that in your heart for the
first time
is transformational oh it is
unbelievable because jesus christ is the
only one that can truly break the chains
of addiction
he's the only one that can level the
mountains of anxiety and fear
and he's done all that and in that
process because i have busy hands and a
skill set being a handyman we completely
gutted i completely go to the kitchen
down to the studs
and rebuild it
with my own hands and that
transformation
of our kitchen in our home
walked right along with jesus rebuilding
a new marriage set on a solid foundation
and we have pictures that we've uploaded
to show that um wow
powerful how old are you
i'm 41
and i am 48. wow
and you so you've been dry two years no
uh it is three years yes it's 37 37
months three years yeah i'm just counted
wow it's huge way to go man thank you so
proud of you thank you this is so very
cool yes so very cool and oh by the way
we got out of debt yeah i mean it's like
that ain't nothing compared to the rest
of this right yeah yeah we retook fpu
together once we had gotten back
together and um that was the first time
we were able to combine our finances
because before when i tried to sit down
and we'd do budget it would just it
would erupt and nothing could
happen so it was amazing that was about
three years ago is when we finally were
able to sit down yeah you all had a lot
of things moving yeah all changing in
this process yeah which is just so
beautiful though because i'm like as you
stand here today it's like you're
completely different people and and most
of the time you know it's obviously the
financial is what brings people here on
the stage and we hear some of the good
stuff right whether it's like you know
our marriage is better you know i have
was i got healthier whatever it is right
but i mean these are big buckets you
guys yeah from sobriety
to finding jesus
to this financial piece i mean all of it
i mean it's incredible so through the
journey you guys worked it together as a
married couple again right so what was
what was difficult about it did these
other things come into play like what
did it what did it feel like what was
hard um i think i think for me uh what
was difficult was that um
it was just
a lot of work i mean once we finally got
into it and got serious about it like
jason was just i mean we both worked
hard but he he works harder than anybody
i've ever met and
um so it's hard to stay connected in
your marriage when you're rarely seeing
each other and you know then just coming
home and crashing you know absolutely
yeah absolutely yeah that is hard
because it takes the hours out of the
day right yeah it is there's a there's a
factor there
so uh
you guys
heather you're having to rebuild trust
yeah it takes a while it's not
instantaneous
if you're smart yeah normal people it
takes a little bit of time to rebuild
trust after that much deception yeah and
um
and so that's by degrees that's by
increment
um and yet you guys are working hand in
hand on the budget during this time with
money were you uh were you trusting each
other on that part too
yeah is that helping with that or is
that hard i think you know to your point
i i that is completely my story and i
think it was hard
sometimes you know like i still had
those like is he still hiding something
from me you know like and
um and it just takes time and
consistency to start and you know and
god in your life to start paving that
trust again you know and um
yeah well that's not that's reasonable
and that's not unfair it's unfair to for
the trust not to be building
but it's it's also unfair to expect it
to be instantaneous correct without a
track record absolutely and so it's very
cool you guys are very well done i mean
it sounds like you've got some wonderful
people around you in your life
uh that are pouring into you and uh
resetting a whole bunch of stuff in your
in your lives a spiritual walk is uh
that you described it's absolutely
powerful that's so well done yeah
there's some good good people there
that's good stuff guys proud of you
and we get to be a tiny little part of
this big story this is a big story here
it's a big one man that's so cool that's
so cool so uh man good good good so now
that you
you know you come back together after
all this stuff and we say all right
we're going to lean in on the money
man that's just
what was yeah what was the big what was
the big factor financially in this in
that part of your story that helped get
out of debt so people listening that may
have have all this life what are you
talking about what do you call them they
gotta do yeah yeah uh one on the same
page right yeah absolutely you have to
be hand in hand you have to be facing it
together
and then um also
when you commit to getting out of debt
and never using a get using debt again
you only have to pay off that credit
card one time
one time and you're done all right count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
106 000 paid off in three and a half
years
heather and jason
three two one
we're dead
[Music]
they are three
three three
wow
wow free on so many levels it's a
beautiful thing oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
psalm 18 30 as for god his way is
perfect the lord's word is flawless he
shields all who take refuge in him
brian tracy said integrity is the most
valuable and respected quality of
leadership always keep your word
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five rachel cruz
ramsey personality is my co-host matt is
in lansing michigan hey matt welcome to
the ramsey show
thank you mr ramsay and ms cruz i
appreciate the time today thank you how
can we help
so my wife and i are big fans uh we're
baby step seven um
we've been following you guys for a
handful of years and it's helped us get
through some some tough times uh in the
past and um we're at a point now where
we've we've got some money saved up and
and we'd like to we'd like to build an
out building on our property and uh and
as you can imagine
uh the price quotes we're getting are
rather outrageous right now um
we have the cash
um but
struggling a little bit parting ways
with it
given the uh
given given the price quotes we're
getting and feeling kind of like is this
inflation thing gonna
turn and should we just wait it out a
little bit more and wanted to get some
of your advice on that
how much you're spending on it
um
it's probably not it's a it's a
good-sized barn it's probably going to
be like 75 to 100 000.
okay and what so your quote let's call
it 100 grand
in current environment in the current
environment what what did you think it
was going to be before all this garbage
hit
uh
i was expecting it to be like
about
like
45
50
so it's almost double what your emotions
were
yeah yeah pretty much okay so what's
your net worth
um 1.7
okay
all right
i mean matt you can
i mean you can take the hit you guys can
do it you have the money
it's not it's not a crazy percentage of
your world uh it's gonna be a nasty pill
to swallow because you're just like oh
but if it's something you you guys want
right now and you're and you have the
cash for it i mean you can do it you can
wait it out the only the hard thing with
waiting it out
for me is we don't know when this is
going to end we talked about a little
bit this last night at the event
um that we had talking about inflation
and all of that but
there's not a crystal ball we don't know
so
i mean so let's say this is 40 000
over
what you wanted to spend
and that's what that's what the algae is
okay
um 40 000 as a percentage of 1.7
it's not a biscuit dude
and you can't buy a biscuit with this i
mean it's not you know it's not that big
a deal if it was 400 000 it was a fourth
of your net worth or something we talk
about waiting and seeing if this
inflation calms down or something but
this is a very small percentage of your
world this is ninety percent emotional
and
uh ten percent mathematical this problem
that you're facing
would you agree with that because the
ratio of your net worth
yeah i i would
uh i hear what you're saying it was
actually uh interesting we were chatting
about it last night we happen to stumble
upon your your live broadcast last night
and my wife said you should just call
dave and ask him what he thinks
i don't know
uh in 36 months could you build that
barn instead of for uh
90 or 100 could you build it for 80
probably
yeah it'll probably come down because
it's cost of lumber cost of labor and
those two things are outrageous right
now and i think they're i i don't think
they're going to stay where they are
so you can probably you probably wait
three years
and save ten thousand dollars or
whatever but you know what you're worth
1.7 million dollars it's 40 grand but
build a barn man
ain't that big a deal
again if it's 400 000 as a percentage of
your world i'd tell you tap the brakes
let's wait throwing this stuff to calm
down but it's 40 grand swing
and and after after you when it swings
back how far is it going to swing it
ain't going to swing back all that 40.
so yeah you know that's true
it is going to come down though i mean i
i think you could look up three years
from now and go i can build that barn
that i just spent 90 on i can build it
for 70 now and i think you'll probably
see that but whoopee
this is why you've done all of this so
you can have this bar i got a feeling
there's a whole lot of stuff in your
head that the enjoyment of this
outbuilding the things you're going to
do here
i i think
it's something that's going to add value
to your life or you wouldn't be talking
about it right and it wouldn't be that
big a strain emotionally if it wasn't
going to add value if it was just kind
of yeah we just wait you know nothing
but you're that's important
about it because it means something you
know so
i i'm building it if i'm in your shoes
and uh by the way i'm building a you
know 2500 square foot auditorium on top
of the hill up here right now and steel
prices doubled uh so um
i bought the steel
before they doubled because i saw part
of it coming
but uh it's still you know stinking not
on budget
um but we're gonna build it we're we're
building it we're finishing it so it's
it's there
and uh fifty thousand square foot of um
uh of of commercial buildings a little
different scale a little different
number zeros on the end of this deal but
it's the same idea that you're but it's
it's a it's a it's a blow we can absorb
and it doesn't change our life
and same with you matt and the enjoyment
and the things that that event center is
going to do
for ramsey solutions and for helping
people is going to be worth whatever
whatever my feelings are heard about
prices right
yeah because that's really what it is it
hurts your feelings
[Laughter]
it makes you angry
the steel did what but the biggest
they want what for the electronics oh my
gosh
you okay yeah i just bought i just we
just bought all the we bought all the
sound system the other day we're putting
in a warehouse because we don't even
need it until the fall but
same thing stinking chips it's just god
but again the in context of this
conversation though it is
because it's
with cash it's a small percentage of the
world that's a mat and your example but
if you are but if you're you know if
you're having to replace a car we talked
about this in the last segment um you
know maybe pause on that if it's a big
part of your world of your world there
are times to pause you guys there are
times to pause and
understand that yeah
that's right that's right i mean you
know it's not a it's a percentage
if you really think things are that this
is going to come down something's going
to come down then you wait it out if
it's a big percentage right right and uh
uh
i think that's the thing
the the um
ratios or that's the principles always
look at the ratio of uh what's going on
here again if he had the ratio an
example would be if it was
at a zero to that or or not even a zero
if you had
half a zero to it it's a 500 000 deal
out of 1.7 then no we're just going to
wait that's right it's too big then you
need to wait that out because it's a lot
of money
in
ratio but i love always the answer spend
it
when it's the wise time when it's wise
and you can do it enjoy it matt like
that's part of it i feel like everyone
thinks like when they think of even
ramsey or the show
it's like oh you gotta just sacrifice
all the time so all you do in life is
just sacrifice sacrifice sacrifice and
yes you do live like no one else so
later you can build the barn but the lit
but the later so you can live and give
like no one else we don't talk about as
much and it's so fun when you're like
yes mats then you can just buy the car
do it look like no one else later you
can build the barn that's right
you know live like no one else you get
to you it gives you margin it gives you
options it gives you choices that's all
money's good all that money is not it's
not good for anything except that right
it's good for the generosity that it can
do it's good for the stability that it
can bring to your life but it's not
really just piling it up in a big old
pile it's not
in and of itself it's of no value it's
what it does
in your life the the it's what you know
the options the the different position
you put yourself in in your
relationships and the different position
you put yourself in in the community and
all of those kinds of things it's a tool
it's a tool it's not the end game it's
not the end i'll be all if it is the end
game you got another problem that's
right you got a spiritual issue yeah
yeah and now you've started worshiping
idols bigger barns bigger barns there
you go
so many barns there's a lot of barns in
this story
hey james it's a family trait it's
friday it's a family trait the exact
wrong metaphors
let us give us a little grace it's
friday
[Music]
i love it this is so fun well done good
show james and ben and justin in the
booth we appreciate you guys rachel
austin i'm sorry and uh i can't get
nothing right awesome good job rachel
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you